the division hunted the third and final
novel in the operation Crossroads Saga
due to be released on January 2nd for
the ebook January 2nd for the US
paperback and March 28th for the UK
paperback as I said this is the last
installment for the operations
Crossroads Trilogy and my God Thomas
parrot ended it with a bang but like
anything to get the maximum out of it I
would highly suggest reading recruited
and compromised before picking this one
up they do a fantastic job for setting
the scene of what is playing out in
hunted my intention is to keep this as
spoiler-free as possible regarding this
novel however if you are planning to
read the earlier books and haven't
gotten around to it yet I would suggest
closing this video now as I'll be
touching on these a little to help build
the setting I'll have a link to my
reviews of the previous two novels in
the
[Music]
description
as a bit of a recap on where the
division compromise took us after their
previous success over the rors it isn't
long before Myra and ell are made aware
of a group of environmental extremists
who are dead set on helping the world
repair their first targets Texan oil
refineries they want to see a world free
from fossil fuels the fuels that are
also helping the truckies Supply the
various settlements of survivors with
food and
supplies after being dispatched they'
also learn of a new private military
company who are acting as the saviors
but also the overlords of these
vulnerable communities with very
different goals in mind these new
factions are a time bomb waiting to
explode and the agents are caught right
in the middle of it by the end of the
book Myra and ell are caught up in a
firefight on an old Battleship against a
group of Rogue agents on board they also
had a huge stockpile of Ken's Eclipse
virus Myra would go on to sacrifice
herself in order to sink the ship and
bury the eclipse virus
compromise ends with Myra waking up in a
hospital her body was badly beaten and
shot up however she's very much alive
but who saved
her the division hunted begins with Myra
canai on the run she is flagged as Rogue
and has no idea that usel is still alive
Brenda Wells The Unofficial cell leader
and the one responsible for recruiting
Myra would eventually learn that she is
still alive she refuses to believe that
Myra has gone Rogue and against the
recommendations of her colleagues she
finds and disables a team to track her
down and learn the truth they would find
themselves fighting through various
obstacles in the blistering heat of the
American southwest a lot of which is
pointing them in the direction of
irrefutable evidence saying that there
is far more to the story that could be
seen from the outside Myra's proven
technological prowess has header become
a focus of concern for all sides of the
conflict so it's of the greatest concern
that she has stopped on top of this
she's been stalked and well hunted by an
unknown and deadly as
salant the story of hunted leads in
directly after the epilog from
compromised where Myra is essentially
brought back from the dead and is in a
Department of Homeland Security facility
receiving some of the best cure and
Rehabilitation available so how did she
suddenly find herself on the
run honestly that's probably all I can
say on the plot without spoiling
anything the first thing I noticed when
starting the book is the pace there was
no long buildup and setting of The Scene
It was just go go go from the very
beginning it's not that the scene wasn't
being built though it was just doing it
in a way that placed just as much
importance on the severe urgency and
panic of the situation playing out the
story has been told from different
perspectives crossing over to different
times and different characters
throughout this is an awesome way to
fill the gaps when you start the story
from halfway through but it also runs
the risk of frustrating the Audience by
making them have to wait too long to
come back to the story arc they may have
been enjoying but I'm happy to say that
this certainly wasn't the case with
hunted in fact I think my poor heart
actually needed it I was getting so
invested into some scenes I was actually
happy for the opportunity to reset my
heart rate when Crossing back over to
different characters on top of this the
gaps weren't too long and by the second
half of the book the different story
arcs rapidly began to converge with each
other I said it before with the other
two and it's the same deal with hunted
just maybe more so if you were a truth
fan of the story surrounding this
franchise you need to get this book
there are some things that novels can do
that the story within the game cannot
video games need to ensure quality of
life and a platform that is fun to play
is it realistic that I can carry 150
weapons on my character at any one time
no but how frustrating would it be to
run back to the safe house every time I
needed to swap Thomas's work provides
in-depth detail about what it's really
like to be a division agent they aren't
the superheroes they can sometimes
appear to be in the game most have been
killed and the ones we follow get shot
up and absolutely beaten to hell and
back shd tech is a finite resource it
isn't just respawning on their backpacks
every 30 seconds they need to pick and
choose the ideal time to use it their
ammo food water and finding a place they
can safely rest is a concern for them at
all times Thomas has done an amazing job
showing how exceptionally difficult it
is for the agents and how Grim their
lives really are one detail I
particularly liked was around a hunter
scene I don't think this is a spoiler
I've seen a lot of people talking about
this online plus it's on the cover
artart we all love the hunters but they
have never felt so damn brutal as they
do after finishing this book there was
even some cool speculation around their
armor and gear which I thought was a
nice
touch another thing that I particularly
like about hunted is that it's caught up
with the current timeline in the game so
we're hearing about a lot of things that
have just happened except from a
different perspective we're seeing that
some things weren't quite as straight
forward as we assumed and that there has
been a huge amount of work and failures
behind the scenes I especially like the
highin with certain characters and the
information we've slowly been collecting
Through The Descent coms in game Thomas
as a writer has really managed to embed
himself into our world the division
universe and bring to light detail that
we've never seen before while I think
the first two novels were fantastic in
their own right they spent a little bit
of time building up to this book and I'm
going to go ahead and say that this is
the best one yet and the perfect end to
the trilogy in fact Ubisoft with
division 3 having now been announced I
think you need to lock Thomas in for a
few more books in anyway thank you very
much to eonite for the review copy of
the book apologies it took me so long to
get to it another thank you to Lauren
stone for in her words being the
psychopath who was able to facilitate
this alongside her other narrative work
in game and last but certainly not least
thank you very much to Thomas parrot
we're a picky Bunch you delved into our
world some of us have been following it
for 8 years plus and we would have been
the first ones to pick holes in it if
you hadn't hit the mark but fortunately
for us you have delivered nothing but
gold I really do hope to see more
division from you in the future
for everyone else thank you very much
for watching and I'll have links for all
three of the novels in the description
[Music]
[Applause]
cheers